so yeah there's gonna be a lot of spoilers here
and so be mindful the short version of how this
movie koi why don't you do the honors of recapping
the short version of uh this movie is a nation in
mourning has to deal with ramifications of an
outside party causing a global conflict it was
uh all about emotional trauma and generational
trauma in a very specific way and therefore the
post-credit scene which we're about to get into
dealing that the most head-on in phase four was
fascinating but it was about taking on a mantle
and it was different ways of viewing leadership
and it was Revenge versus Vengeance versus
Authority versus leadership and all of these
very very broad themes with a juxtaposition
of aggressive violence and sensory overload
intermixed with powerful poignant silence it's
it's a lot of movie that does not explain how we
get to the post credit I'm so used to not spoiling
like I'm so careful that I'm like can I talk about
it like I'm so afraid like I feel the snipers
like Kevin feige's behind me isn't he you're right
nothing away that was literally the most lawyer I
could have done the plot the color blue represents
what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here today to talk about the Black
Panther wakanda forever post credit scene we want
to talk about our emotional response to it why I
think it's probably Marvel's best or at least one
of the best post-credit scenes they've ever had
and of course what this could mean for the future
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe and joining me
today is koi the genre who is killing it on the
tick tocks lately he's got a solo review up here
on the channel he's watching it again because
we have to do a live stream spoiler talk this
coming Saturday so ladies and gentlemen leave a
like subscribe click that notification Bell get
notified when our spoiler talk is uh going live
so I'm just gonna give you guys the the briefest
version of the book on forever ending of how it
went down so we could talk about the post-credits
scene and hopefully this just sounds very natural
as I go into it alright so at the end of the movie
after the conflict with wakanda and the people
of talocon has been put to rest at least so it
seems sure he goes to visit Nokia and Haiti where
Nokia has been residing but before the credits
roll shuri is readying herself to let go at this
time of grief and burn t'challa's white robes on
the beach do it alone something that she refused
to do earlier in the film in the mid-credits
scene however Nokia joined shuri on the beach but
she has a kid with her who we end up learning is
t'challa's son who goes by the name to Saint but
whose real name is actually also t'challa making
him Prince t'challa now before we dive into the
details of this post-credits scene I just gotta
say in that ending itself just like before the
credits start rolling before the mid-credits
scene I love the way they captured it because
when she's on the beach and then she closes
her eyes and it's just silence you could feel
the waves it feels truly mournful and sorrowful
mirroring the opening MCU credits which is my
favorite I think remix of what that world is
like the the movie opens with just a Chadwick
tribute and the opening MCU credits were set
to silence or set to win basically and then the
the wind we hear at the very end of the film so
it bookends the film and I totally agree that was
such a powerful remorseful moment but I also love
that the last bit of levity we had before that was
her being like I've got to go do something first
and then it gives you the three things she might
be doing like I love that it was like it cuts to
the ceremony that mbaku was taking over it cuts to
harass it gives you like oh I bet she's doing that
and then what she's actually doing is this and I
was really impressed that I was like oh she's oh
like they actually got me and then it was the most
sad possible [__] ending which was great in the
mid-credits scene itself what I love so much
of why I think it's one of the best mid-credit
scenes in in any of Marvel is because the movie
honestly could have just ended right there with
shuri crying letting go like getting to the stage
of grief of acceptance because acceptance doesn't
mean like I'm happy acceptance is I'm ready to
move on now I'm ready to let go as hard as it
is I'll never forget you you'll always be in my
memories you'll always be with me but that doesn't
mean that I have to just be in Anger anymore you
know the four prior stages to acceptance of grief
so it could have ended right there and what I love
about that new credit scene is that feels like an
epilogue and or the real ending of the film most
of the time these mid credit scenes or post-credit
scenes purely feel like a setup for the future
they feel like a commercial is what I'm getting
at and a lot of times that commercial is awesome
and exciting I love them but it's a commercial it
is mainly just a commercial like a lot of times
the movies don't need that this one felt like it
really completed the film it completed the actual
story for it and gave a resolve it's the exact
opposite of how I felt about the Moon Knight post
credit sure in that the Moon Knight post-credit is
literally the same format as this where it's the
scene ends the scene continues then it really ends
but in Moon night it felt like it undercut the
ending of the first one whereas this one it felt
like it bolstered the entire film this is just
an emotional Landing this is a a continuation
of a scene that felt like like you said could
have ended it's resolve versus like gotcha and
it didn't feel I don't know cliche yeah because
it ends with shuri in pain but the post-credits
scene gives hope and joy true happiness for
the first time like as as heartbreaking as as
tearful as it is like man a lot of people were
I've never seen some people cry at a mid credit
scene before hey it tells you like what Nokia
why she really wasn't there the whole time it
gives a real explanation because you know Washi
explains that yeah he was my everything to Okoye
that she couldn't be there for present for any
of this because it was too painful for for her
you find out there was actually a deeper reasoning
that involved t'challa and why Sween raimondo was
okay with that like I love that that one line gave
us closure for raimonda's Arc and her experience
and we it also gave us a moment of realizing that
you know Angela Bassett got to meet her grandchild
like that was a beautiful moment even dialogue and
I don't know who this boy is but I swear because
she has what they reveal is that Nakia had a son
with t'challa so basically instead of dealing with
the pressure of being the son of t'challa instead
of dealing with the pressure of being the assumed
ruler of an entire nation and seeing what that had
done to t'challa they have him be raised in Haiti
and I love this name choice I really love and
full credit to John basically this character is
the prince t'challa which to me is this beautiful
message of rebirth that the entire phase four has
been about the phase four experience has been
morning therapy going through the processes of
grief and then rebirth and the reason this is a
post-credit scene that I think sings higher than
most is you get this great tease with one name
much like a secret identity and then you reveal
the true name the hero the moment and that's true
rebirth we see King t'challa in Him and then we
hear he's Prince t'challa son of King t'challa
and you get rebirth in real time you get the
experience of shuri having this revelatory moment
and seeing her brother and someone else seeing her
her pride and her sorrow and her Joy all of that
conveyed in once and we're having that emotional
experience because of our connection to the actor
chapter Boseman and the character of t'challa call
this in 30 seconds oh my God this kid this kid
looks like genius it looks like incredible like
I was like is that Chadwick boseman's kid because
he he looks so much like like him that I was like
the second you see him and you're like oh that's
to Charles tell us all yeah every second you see
him yeah his smile the way is like his face
lights up feels like when Chadwick had that
like the presence he's the presence of Bozeman
which is incredible you weren't specifying why
we're recording John I got excited about it
John is because he goes by a name but is real
name is t'challa but the name that he goes by the
Haitian name is Toussaint and John was saying that
he thinks it's uh in tribute to to Sante who was
a Haitian General and a prominent leader of the
Haitian revolution so you know I feel like John's
probably correct about that and that's so genius
to have the both of his names have resonance like
I love my name and I think a unique name really
shapes who you are as a person so I love that
he got to have a name that symbolizes something
in Haiti as well as a name that is part of his
identity because t'challa identifying as the
king of wakanda as well as the Black Panther as
well as all these things I feel like this already
gives that kid a lot of that like a name has power
I loved the way how Leticia writes performance
in that moment is reacting to him because in the
ending she's so just heartbroken and Shadow like
this is so painful for her and then she's got
a different kind of melancholic Joy there yeah
like that when she is she seems so genuinely happy
to be interacting with this boy and it gives her
hope for the future and then on top of that too
you know it does set up the possibility or the
likelihood of we will have to teach us so everyone
was like recast the child we will have a t'challa
in the future and it will be in the form of this
boy when he's probably grown up now I'm hearing a
lot of people speculate maybe they'll do some type
of time Jump or some Secret Wars thing that will
lead to him just being older or something like
that what do you think is going to happen here
with the future of this boy I think he's going to
be a young Avenger I think that he's only a little
younger than the well I mean the Young Avengers
are kind of a huge swath of Ages right now if you
look at them but if you look at the Young Avengers
so far the swath of Ages is pretty crazy like Eli
Bradley and Falcon the Winter Soldier the grandson
who we are getting that actor back in the upcoming
Captain America four Eli Bradley is like I don't
know 12 13. and this kid looks like he's probably
like eight or nine and then you've got people
as old as Kate Bishop who's like grown anyway
you've got you've got like a 10-year span So Young
Avengers I think allows for flexibility I wouldn't
age him up it feels like an odd thing to to play
with with someone going through rebirth like he's
already representing a rebirth of t'challa I think
aging him up would feel kind of like soft it'd
feel like a an Easy Choice instead of like letting
him grow as I want to see the Journey of when that
boy has to go back to wakanda or go to wakanda for
the first time yeah and has to deal with all the
things that Nokia and t'challa were worried about
him having to deal with you know his innocence and
his Joy juxtaposing Michael B Jordan's Vengeance
like he went to wakanda and he went as I'm gonna
take over things using this I'd love to see him go
and have that sense of awe and wonder but the way
that boy delivered um I'm playing God of War again
boy uh the way the way that little boy delivered
that line of when he says my name is tacha I
forget exactly what that line is but the way he
says it there is such a demonstration of strength
responsibility and acceptance in it it's not like
some cute kid actor being like I'm you know do
that presence you could feel the setup of the
future with this kid based off of his delivery of
he is priming himself mentally and emotionally to
go to wakanda one day it hit me really hard in
real life my experience of how important it is
to talk about death With Children yeah like I had
a moment of I love how she has addressed that his
father is gone with a sense of joy and pride like
he wasn't sad talking about t'challa she was proud
of his father when they said Baba it felt like
a moment for him not like oh and I feel like a
lot of people just talk about death so sadly and
lost so sadly it was really an impactful moment
for me as a human to be like death is inevitable
and death is a part of our experience so we need
to address things in a way that it doesn't [__]
us and I really love how this is all I'm like this
is a 30 second scene like this scene is not
long and we're like this riveted by it yeah
it's I I thought it was like just the more I talk
about it the more it moves up I'm having motions
right now remembering the emotions I had that
is possibly my favorite because yeah it's not
as exciting as like we're starting an Avengers
Initiative or some [__] like that right it's
not as exciting as that because you're not gonna
be like you know when it's done I think in terms
of hitting you in the fields hitting you in
the heart and Landing an emotional beat to
feel like the true button on the film that is
why I rank it so high the emotion was different
because there was that blend of melancholy
and hope it's a really beautiful emotional
resonance it leaves you with well it's also the
playing on something real life with the passing
of Chadwick Boseman you know so it does feel like
more than to Charles Legacy lives on it feels like
Chadwick boseman's Legacy will live on and then
the Chadwick foundation in the credits not long
after like there's a foundation of arts for him
and and you know that's just to me mirrors what
the end of the movie felt like because obviously
his hands were all over it and there's that moment
where uh Angela Bassett talks about uh his hand
on her shoulder uh and that's something that they
kept referring to on set like Ryan coogler talked
about when he was film filming he felt Chadwick's
hand in his shoulder and like the fact that they
were using things of their real life experiences
and art that's what art is four is to is to like
process emotion I love that this post-credits
scene much like them using Chadwick's hand is a
processing of emotion and I think that's really
cathartic for both the audience the creators
the filmmakers the experience of how important
black panther is two people how much more than
just a character he is to an entire people and
how this child seems to understand in this
portrayal like I don't know the child but in
this portrayal the weight of that yes yeah I don't
know any Marvel postcardism where you would talk
like this about it so that's why it's my favorite
I think it's a uniquely emotional experience and
I don't think that's going to be for everyone
because I think people go to these movies for
different reasons I think wakanda forever won't
be for everyone oh definitely not I'm avoiding
the Rotten Tomatoes score I I don't care to argue
with people I know how much this movie hit me and
I don't want to deal with just I'm like half of me
doesn't want to do a spoiler talk because I'm like
I just don't want to deal with the people coming
in and yelling with me and I'm like all right I
understand what I do so yeah yeah I'm going to
do it but I don't really want to do it I left
the Press screening and stood outside by myself
before I filmed anything so I wanted to process
it anyway I thought it was a beautiful movie and
I thought the post-credit scene was very beautiful
very impactful so yeah guys what'd you guys think
about it leave your thoughts down below what do
you think it means for the future subscribe click
that Bell leave a like like I wanted to shoot for
10. we shot for 20. that's what we do that's
what we do what we do we like talking I mean
with the three hour editing session course that's
why I'm here all right guys see you soon [Music]